hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're having kind of a
departure from our normal format instead
of me lecturing with a whiteboard I'm
actually going to be asking my
grandmother some questions about her
recollections with the disease caused by
hookworm so this is my grandmother her
name is Doris she was born in 1933 and
so we're going to be talking a little
bit about hookworm today some of you may
have heard of hookworm before there's
over 500 million cases in the in the
around the world these days even though
it is really uncommon in the United
States now it actually used to be a much
larger problem especially in the
southeastern United States because
hookworm is transmitted through the
soles of the feet so a person will walk
across contaminated soil soil that's
been contaminated by human feces and the
hookworm can actually burrow up through
the soles of their feet and then enter
their body and cause a pretty severe
infection and so it is something that is
related to hygiene and sanitation issues
so that's why I want to talk to my
grandmother Doris to ask what was it
like when you were growing up so in the
1930s and 1940s did you have in Norfolk
no indoor plumbing yes
no indoor plumbing so how did how did
your family use bathroom
we had an outhouse outhouse two-seater
that's case anybody else want to come
and join me
two people wanted to use it at once so
the outhouse how far was it from your
home what distance is nine feet or so
yeah and I didn't want to smell the area
yeah it's really good for if you do have
an outhouse for it to be quite a
distance from your home so that if there
is some sort of contamination issues
you're less likely to be walking through
it in your yard did you go barefoot a
lot when you were a little Oh done all
the time she's growing up and sort of
rural Arkansas in the 30s and 40s when
did your mother let you go barefoot we
only got two
go barefoot in May June July August yeah
we could we could not go barefoot and a
month that had our I never understood
that but that was my mother's rule yeah
so she would let you go barefoot when it
was warm outside and those were the
months that didn't have an arm yeah
did you ever hear about hookworm when
you might have heard about it yes I
don't recall ever anybody ever having it
that I knew but I'm sure my mom she
mentioned people that had it but I
didn't know them you know do you feel
like there was any stigma around people
who had hookworm like what did other
people think of a person if they had
hookworm but they were dirty
they were dirty that they were walking
through poop in the dirt yeah and they
didn't take baths every day like they do
now
you know if they took a bath on Saturday
in the summertime that was probably it
you know so yeah they they got it from
the dirt and not washing hands and
you're doing stuff like that and so of
course we know today that hookworm only
burrows through the feet it doesn't
really have anything to do with
hand-washing or how often you bathe
because the hookworm can burrow into the
soles of your feet in just a couple of
minutes so you could still take a bath
every day but if you've walked barefoot
through a contaminated area then you can
still get hookworm so just kind of goes
to show some of the stigma that can be
and some of those sort of misinformation
that can surround something like that
of course we never hear about hook room
anymore but if there's a hookworm in the
United States it turns out that there is
for a long time it was thought that
hookworm had more or less than
eradicated in the United States and now
just within the last maybe three or four
years it's been determined that there's
still hookworm and especially poverty
stricken areas in the extreme southeast
we're talking about mainly I think
Alabama and Mississippi in very very
poor communities again where there's no
indoor plumbing where people have
outhouses right
right there their front doors so if
you're interested in learning more about
that you can actually do a Google search
for hookworm in the United States and
that should bring up articles for you
from things like NPR and The Guardian
and Fox News that will give you more
information about that but that's it for
today so I want to say thank you to my
Mimi for telling us a little bit about
her her memories and her experiences and
thanks for watching biology professor
and we'll see you next time